disadvantage in the world I think is
nonsense you're at an advantage of some
disadvantage the world is a lot kinder
to you and your young attractive female
than if you're a young man well if
you're what you're not yeah
if you're if you're then if you're in
shape you're attractive to maybe not to
all men but most men men's fight right
now yeah if you're in shape if you have
a nice body most memorable attractive
there's some there's some people who are
like
so again I'm not on your will agenda but
there's people there's people that come
in with maybe maybe it's just jeans
maybe it's like disabilities or whatnot
everyone comes in different like shapes
and sizes somebody who's not like
um how can I say somebody who's not
obese or not pretty like slim or
whatever but it can't get in shape
because of X Y or Zed like I think
that's a lie I think they eat less
exercise more stop it like come on stop
it I don't like you don't go to like
third world countries and see obesity
the same way you see it in the west that
is yeah but that's consumerism that's
not that's nothing to do
the choice to eat more if somebody is
out but exercise live no no if someone's
enough and I'm talking about both ends
of the skill if I've come from a third
world country
and I've moved to you know let's say
I've moved to America and I can eat as
much as I want but just based on again
Gene's history my metabolism doesn't let
it like grow under like I can be like
you know how can I say I cannot be in
shape but I'm not like fat you know what
I mean no what does in-shapely mean
exactly it's very subjective which is
what I'm guessing it's in shape
subjective yes it is yes it is it is 100
I mean
what are you in shape right now I would
say I am but people would look at you
and they would and say you're in shape
like it's very subjective bro I mean I
think you can plus or minus 20 pounds
where people would argue like you know
what I'm saying like I think there's 20
pounds where like some people would say
yes some people would say no but on the
each end there's no like you're not
you're not looking at like a pro athlete
and saying are you in shape and a 300
pound whale
they're not in shape like it's not
there's no argument
every single time
the cutoff yeah but there's not two ends
of dirt it's not like in shape and fat
it's like it's very much like it's very
much wise
oh skinny fat no just kidding
the point that I'm making is as a
woman's in your control you get I know a
lot of guys that say she might not have
the best face but she has like a nice
butt or banging butt whatever it is but
what if you're pulled with that's what
I'm saying you're born with low back no
chest like how is that your fault like
what are you supposed to do that
no no no no no no no I said look back no
chest the chest thing that's up to you
for to get a blue job but I don't need
that you don't need it I said up to you
okay yeah
who's funding it you get it
you can get it okay
is unattractive women only swipe right
five percent of the time on dating apps
so it's like
oh there's a but like most men will
still find you attractive if you're in
shape fifty percent
yeah you know um when I was in high
school my classmates they believe me one
guy said
um he had a dream that he was having sex
with me he woke up and he was touching
the wall oh bro
[Music]
I could I could sit on this all day but
that person who's shaped like a wolf are
they in shape like are they attractive
no but she's a wolf you can build a bus
now you can build the bus
like uh what is I'm not gonna move to
any goal because like like if I'm not
looking there you need to have you have
to have stuff okay but you remember like
you have options most men don't
yeah one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the last
year under 30. so so you you have a
girlfriend right yeah so and she
probably wasn't the only girl you could
have dated right so you have
you know I'm playing with it
take what she said literally is she the
only girl I could have dated yeah right
right is she the only girl I was dated
hey hey all right you see how they try
to sleep they got a couple Yankees yeah
they've got a couple Yankees out here
trying to catch me I'm listening I'm
listening so how tall are you
I I don't know
it's not six five it's not six four
about okay you're top like what five
percent of guys in terms of height over
six foot is top 15 percent sure so yeah
you you have the option to be selective
most men don't so am I gonna cry you a
river that the top 10 of guys aren't
giving you attention 90 will like that's
how I say stop it for these women that
boohoo my life's so hard
even if we up it to like say the top 20
30 of men don't find you attractive
bottom 60 will even if you have no back
no like you think the dot the bottom 30
are crying are like that picky
no hey I don't know I don't know that's
true I don't know about sex in a year
how picky are you gonna be
because men it's like you have a
biological imperative to find as many
women attractive as possible like women
look to disqualify men look to qualify
so it's like if you if you're at a bar
and you think this girl might come home
with you and at first you're like and
you have a couple drinks you're like you
know what she's hot they're you know
maybe she doesn't have the best face but
she's got an ass that'll do and you're
not angry because you could pick one
do you pay scented best it was it was
ludicrous sorry T-Pain was in the song
um
if that's what you want me to do a gap
tooth and a mean over by your face was
horrible yeah but she had a body yeah
from England but that game deadly all
right man
yesterday
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible